l'été est arrivé à constanta le soleil
la mer l'air salin ces femmes en avaient
besoin
ça nous rappelle odessa c'est la même
mer la mer noire et elle est magnifique
avons et moretti on veut rentrer à la
maison
olga elena larissa tatiana ina ne se
connaissaient pas quand elles se sont
réfugiés sur la côte roues mais
aujourd'hui elles sont inséparables
elle habite l'hôtel mondial juste en
face de la plage elles sont logées
nourries trois fois par jour est bien
entouré
les enfants s'y sont habitués mais
devront bientôt tout recommence
car dans quelques semaines ses plages
désertes de constanta seront bondi de
vacances
l'hôtel leur a donné quelques jours pour
faire leurs bagages et s'ajuster
du camp romain lui a gentiment offert un
studio à mamaya pas très loin mais elle
ne sait pas comment elle va pouvoir
payer la nourriture
les économies fondent avec la guerre qui
s'installe la roumanie leur donner une
protection temporaire le droit de
travailler mais il faudra des mois sinon
plus pour apprendre le roumain
les voir partir sans le sou leur dire de
s'en aller crève le coeur de stefano né
à un hôtelier
écosse
c'est lui qui gère l'hôtel mondiale
il a accueilli plus de cent cinquante
neuf ukrainiens dont 60 enfants depuis
la fin du mois de février sans recevoir
un sou du gouvernement l'état lui a
promis éventuellement 10 euros par
personne par jour pas grand chose dit il
alors que les chambres se loue pour une
centaine d'euros au tourisme
et c'est le dilemme de ces hôtels qui
longe la côte et qui se prépare pour la
saison touristique
car c'est la société civile jusqu'ici
qui s'est démené pour les accueillir
avec dignité cosmin est un coordinateur
qui fait le pont entre plusieurs ong
costanza
où il a aidé à ouvrir cette école au
centre-ville pour les petits ukrainiens
avec ludmila qui elle aussi réfugiés de
la guerre elle devait recevoir des
ballons et des jouets de l'unicef
les enfants dit-elle seront ravis
nous n'avons pas demandé de chanter pour
la caméra ce sont eux qui ont insisté et
ont entonné cette vieille chanson
cosaques de leur pays six pièces ben
rhodes
au fond de la classe sacha est discret
et un des plus calmes il sort un petit
morceau de papier avec un drap pour eux
c'est le cash aussitôt que la maîtresse
approche de lui
[Musique]
c'est la tête de poutine dit il mais
c'est son petit frère ces enfants ne
peut faire autrement qu en vouloir à cet
homme qui détruit leur maison ils font
pleurer leur mère
avec les bombardements qui s'intensifie
à odessa anna se résigne à cette
nouvelle vie en roumanie
à mon rôle de bâton
elena ne sait pas quoi faire et elle est
dévastée
elle se lève incapable de parler elle
nous explique plus tard qu elle aussi
vient d'apprendre qu'elle doit libérer
sa chambre la semaine prochaine elle ne
sait pas où aller
adrian qui est aussi un hôtelier déplore
le fait que l'union européenne est
toujours pas élaboré de plan à long
terme alors qu'il est évident que la
guerre s'éternise elle a débloqué un
fonds de 3 5 milliards d'euros pour les
pays membres qui ont ouvert leurs bras
aux ukrainiens mais c'est long
en attendant pour ces femmes il ya des
centres communautaires ou des dortoirs
et elle n'oserait jamais ce plan
pour la reconnaissance envers le peuple
roumain et sa générosité
les chante elle aussi comme par instinct
de survie leur mal du pays
odessa leurs villes leurs maisons leurs
hommes sont si proches il n'aurait
jamais paru ciller